françois durpaire merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors on vient
de le dire dans la trempe qui n'a rendu
aucun hommage était même absent de ces
funérailles pourquoi il ya effectivement
plusieurs il a eu plusieurs occasions de
rendre hommage à john lewis la présence
physique aux obsèques
fo-ratp que les trois derniers
présidents aient été présents georges de
bol du bush bill clinton et barack obama
dont des républicains et des démocrates
il aurait pu rendre hommage par
l'intermédiaire de tweets c'est son
habitude on aurait pu imaginer un
hommage numérique il aurait pu aller
voir sa dépouille
lorsqu'elle est passée à washington il a
redit depuis de tout cela alors pourquoi
bien la réponse ou l'avait donnée en
introduction il a répondu à assouan
axios 2h bio
il y a quelques jours il a dit eh bien
il n'est pas vu il n'est pas venu
john lewis avant l'investiture il n'est
pas venu non plus écouté mon discours
sur l'état de l'union donc ce n'est pas
acceptable c'est une très grande erreur
c'est à dire qu'il a placé sa relation
personnelle avec john lewis devant
finalement l'histoire et même qu'en soit
l'action lui a demandé mais finalement
au delà de la relation qui est ce que
vous pouvez dire quelque chose de john
lewis et de ses 17 mandat au congrès et
de son rôle dans les droits civiques et
bien donald trump a refusé et a dit non
je ne peux pas dire que cette personne
rend store restera dans l'histoire
alors à quel point justement john lewis
a marqué l'histoire des états unis
alors john et oui il savait il est né en
1940 dans ce qu'on appelle à la black
belt la ceinture noire dans l'alabama à
choï au moment où les lynchages été très
très fréquent encore aux états unis d'un
d'un arrière grand père esclaves est
bien lisse est totalement impliqué dans
les droits civiques il a il a été arrêté
45 fois il a été battu à de nombreuses
reprises par la police par les
suprémacistes blancs
mais la grande date c'est le 7 mars 1965
il est très jeune
et il est le leader et bien de cette
manifestation pour le droit de vote
c'est ce qu'on a appelé le bloody sunday
parce que c'est évidemment très mal
terminée il a été roué de coups par la
police il a été laissé pour mort avec le
crâne fracturé il est avant ce trait à
ce moment là dans l'histoire américaine
comme le plus jeune membre des droits
civiques et comme l'un des instigateurs
du droit de vote et de la loi de 1965 le
voting rights act
alors justement ou pas renié de cette
interview et du civil rights act 1 hier
donald trump nouveauté la romieu oui il
a rentré en soit 124 et en 65
alors on 64 justement les civils heure
est aux teintes et et pour lequel on
s'est battus notamment john lewis il l'a
remis en cause donald trump dans son
interview il a dit un jeu si tant est ce
que cela a vraiment bien fonctionné
est ce que c'est un peu une relecture de
l'histoire de la part du président
américain
oui vous avez raison de poser la
question c'est à dire que il il ya deux
hypothèses qui peut-être explique
l'absence d'hommage de la part de
trappes la première il peut-être c'est
évidemment celle de la relation
personnelle
john lewis est un opposant à ma
politique
et moi je ne les accepte pas de neutre
n'accepte pas qu'on s'oppose à ma
politique
ça c'est présent mais il ya une autre
hypothèse qui est le fait que le
président américain est bien n'accepte
pas le passé notamment la question des
droits civiques et il ya plusieurs
indices qui est haï cette hypothèse des
propos sur les suprémacistes blancs les
propos notamment sur au moment de la
journée d'indépendance du jour
d'indépendance sur l'histoire et sur le
déboulonnage des statuts il a dit donald
trump on déboulonne nos héros est ce que
nos héros sont des esclavagistes et est
ce que nos héros sont des généraux de
l'armée confédérée du sud
et c'est là la grande question il ya un
consensus aujourd'hui aux états unis à
ces majoritaire sur les mêmes même très
majoritaire
la question des droits civiques qu'on
soit finalement un américain
progressiste démocrate ou un américain
plus conservateurs républicains et bien
les droits civiques qui luttait contre
la ségrégation ses rentrées dans les
manuels scolaires comme un héritage
important de des états unis sauf
évidemment dans cette frange très
marginale de suprémacistes ou de
nostalgiques de cette histoire esclavage
et de cette histoire c'est rega sioniste
donc c'est évidemment ce qui pose
problème ce qui dérange aujourd'hui aux
états unis
donald trump a choisi une voie
extrêmement marginale et en fait c'est
toute la politique c'est impoli c'est un
président disruptif c'est sa stratégie
ce qu'on a appelé la stratégie du sud
aller chercher des voix dans le sud des
états unis parmi ces électeurs masculin
blanc qui ont fait son élection de 2016
en grande partie merci beaucoup françois
durpaire d'avoir répondu à nos questions
gpl que vous êtes historien spécialiste
des états unis